uncle jack as well as this whole gang
are some of the most disturbed people in
breaking bad
as their heartless actions reveal time
and time again
from enslaving jesse to sporting various
um
interesting tattoos it's clear that the
gang feels no remorse for their actions
and truly believes in their superiority
but during their time taking out targets
and making deals with lunatic lydia
how much does uncle jack and the gang
make
well starting off most of uncle jack's
time was spent fulfilling hit requests
so we'll start off by estimating his
income from this
the show never reveals how much walter
or lydia pay for their hits
so we're going to have to turn to some
external sources
wikipedia suggests that a hit usually
costs between five and thirty thousand
dollars
with the average costing fifteen
thousand dollars walter
likely paid much more than this per
person as he had a high volume request
and very special instructions
furthermore walter required the gain to
use people on the inside
who would also need to be paid but the
average hit
probably cost about fifteen thousand
dollars in the breaking bad universe
there are several members in a group
however so we'll say the gang charges a
bit more
at 20k per on average as for how
often they take out a target well they
roughly take out one person per month
it's probably more like four in a single
month and then a few months without any
but on average we'll say they get 12
hits
with 12 hits per year at 20 grand each
the gang would pull in a total
of 240 000 per year now their final
income
was likely much higher than this ranging
into the several hundred thousand dollar
range
however at the start before they
establish a reputation
they likely pulled in less than 100
grand per year so
we'll say that a quarter million is the
average they pull in per year throughout
their careers
as for how long they've been in the
business uncle jack is estimated to be
in his mid-50s
according to the breaking bad fan page
so the gang likely has about 20 to 30
years under their belts
estimating 25 years the gang would have
pulled in a total of 6.25 million
dollars
as you can see though they were quite
well off
the money per member is only a little
over a million dollars
which is very low especially for two to
three decades in the underworld
but this would all change when todd
meets walter
though todd quickly becomes walter's lab
partner after mike and jesse step out
he doesn't take any extra pay stating
that he can get paid
after he gets it right considering that
walter has about five months of smooth
cooking with
todd we'll say that for the first two
months he simply makes his vomit's peska
which is 10k per cook
for the next three months however we'll
say that he gets a solid 20
of wall's total profit so to estimate
how much todd makes
we have to take a look at how many cooks
walter is able to complete within these
five months
from mike's breakdown of their profit
here is what we understand
walter reveals that they should be
pulling in 1.379 million per cook
after dealers cut with a dealer cut of
this indicates that they were producing
roughly 43 pounds per cook
out of this revenue 278 000 goes to
mules
135 000 goes to ira who is the owner of
vomiter's pests
and his guys also get 10k each per cook
mike grabs 30k as their cut meaning that
there are only three of these guys
on top of this stahl gets 54 grand and
the legacy costs are 351 thousand
this should leave a total of 531
thousand dollars for mike
walter and jesse however walter reveals
that they're only left with 137 thousand
dollars each
which leaves 120 000 unaccounted for
this probably went to the cost of
materials or some other sort of
miscellaneous costs
once jesse and mike leave however walter
no longer has to split the pot and is
also able to keep the legacy costs for
himself
meaning that walter profits a total of
000 per cook or about 750 grand
we know that walter was able to profit
80 million dollars by the end of the
five months
however that's after paying jesse 5
million and paying uncle jack for the
hits
so walter likely made upwards of 100
million in those
5 months of which he kept 80 million
at this point we also have to keep in
mind that walter has to pay
top 20 of his profit during the last
three months of this time period
assuming a constant cook rate for 40 of
the time
walter was making the full 750 thousand
dollars per cook
and for the other 60 of the time he was
making six hundred thousand dollars per
cook
having paid twenty percent or one
hundred fifty thousand dollars to todd
this means that the weighted average
profit for water per cook
is 660 thousand dollars to make upwards
of 100 million dollars in those five
months
walter would have to complete 151 cooks
or write about one cook per day
which comes out to 300 pounds per week
with all of this information
we can finally estimate how much todd
made from walter's cooks
for the first 60 cooks todd would have
made 10k each
coming out to 600 000 for the next 90
cooks
todd would have made 150 000 per cook
which comes out to a whopping 13.5
million dollars
meaning that todd made a total of 14
million dollars from walter
and that makes sense todd made about 15
of what the mastermind himself made by
being his right hand man
adding this to the gang's hit profit
this pulls up their total income to
20.25 million
at this point they accidentally stumble
upon a jackpot
as they come across walt's secret stash
walter
stores 80 million within 7 barrels and
the gang steals 6 of these barrels
giving them an additional 68.5 million
pushing them up to 88.75 million dollars
and that finally brings me on to the
gang's dealings with lydia by using
jessie
at this point i don't think the gang
really needs
or wants the money as they seem to be
quite content with their little
establishment
on the outskirts of albuquerque really
the main reason i think they form a
partnership with lydia
is to help todd with his relationship
goals but they do profit quite a bit
from this partnership
so we'll take a look at this as well
lydia
only needs 25 pounds per week for the
czech republic of which she takes a 30
cut and considering that labor from
jesse is free
uncle jack's gang profits a nice 70
percent
at the same 2500 per ounce this
partnership brings in 700 grand per week
but that's not it at the start of this
relationship
uncle jack's king takes out the gain
that walter was selling to
which gives him a minimum of 300 pounds
per week in market share
as that's how much water was roughly
producing for them to distribute
however we don't really know to what
extent uncle jack took advantage of this
new market share
the thing is they didn't really care
about torturing jesse for the money
but rather because he's a rat so i'm not
sure how much they would have cared
about taking over this territory
but they did have a full-on industrial
lab
which would easily be able to produce
200 pounds per week just like goss's lab
and if they work jesse over time they
could have likely produced upwards of
300 pounds per week
i just don't know if they really cared
to do that though
but if they did they could have easily
taken over 75 percent of that market
supporting another 225 pounds in
production per week
assuming that they paid 20 to the meals
and 20 to the dealers
they would profit 60 percent they
probably didn't have to pay lydia
as she doesn't really have anything to
do with this other than the original
methylamine that she helped steal
which i don't think she was ever paid
for but will say that they throw 10
to lydia for todd meaning that uncle
jack's king profits 50
from this 225 pounds per week which
comes out to 4.5 million per week
adding this to the 700 grand they get
per week from the czech republic
they pull in roughly 5.2 million per
week given that this arrangement lasts
for 6 months
that gives us 26 weeks of profit but
we'll call it 24 to account for any
issues
at that rate they would make 124.8
million dollars
making the total a cool 213.55 million
so at the end of the day uncle jack's
gang was worth 200 million dollars
plus or minus 20 million but this never
really was the mystery
the real mystery is where they were able
to stuff 200
billion dollars where do you guys think
they kept all this money
comment that down below also if you guys
like the depth of this analysis
drop a like and consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one
you